[Applause]
[Music]
yeah what a day what a day it's
beautiful incredible energy in the
studio tonight yes yes
it's different it's special you can tell
backstage you could tell that stage
watching when i was working that crowd
up front you could tell i was playing
with amazing
[Music]
the only way to put it but you know what
i've noticed and i've been watching this
for a while conan it's interesting
because uh i mean what you do is
incredible i mean your energy is amazing
well thank you
but there's just one thing there's just
one thing that every time i watch the
show it kind of drives me a little crazy
you kind of you find a flaw just one
little thing it's no big deal and it's
never gonna you know hurt the show or
anything right right but when you come
out and you do your dance you know what
i mean yes you come out let me just i
mean so you come out
beginning of the show yeah yeah huge
energy you're walking up you're doing
your thing right and then you jump onto
the star right yes yes yes perfect and
then you go to max yeah you're right you
can't yeah and then you do your little
pivot right right and then you lick your
fingers right you pull your jacket back
right and you do your little string
dance
[Applause]
yeah but now here is where you go a
little rye
go a little awry because
what happens is when you pull this hand
up right you come over here now and you
cut the strings and drop yes
but anybody who knows anything about
physics would know that the string comes
from the top
so you have to cut the string from the
top and then drop otherwise you're tied
to the floor you're cutting something
and going up like this and releasing it
seriously
can we
can we get a cl do we have can we get a
clip of that or something can you can
they put a clip of that up
[Applause]
it doesn't make sense i have the right
to defend myself here this string is
going from the hip to the hand the hip
is dropping
[Applause]
i stand corrected
oh i'm so glad i'm so glad you told me
i've been so confused
well i hope it's clear to everyone i
think we've just cleared up i better get
that yeah see now oh man i'm the only
stupid man in america
no no it's very complicated i'd like me
to miss something these forces were
toying with her i'm just going to offer
you some classes because i teach a lot
of physical comedy i teach physical
comedy i was going to say no you won't
even have to go through the levels you
know you're just like but you're the
master now thank you thank you thank you
but i want to talk about you no one
wants to talk about me really i've asked
no one wants to okay
let's talk about you this is a big movie
you're out promoting well there's water
spilled all over the place yes when you
okay that's not
you don't know where that table's been
you don't want to waste that there's a
transit strike you're right
you got to save that water exactly big
movie out there fun with nick and jane
but the title doesn't explain it so you
probably want to explain this movie to
people okay well here it is um it's
about a uh professor of theology
who's uh called to the scene of a murder
in the louvre
and he finds a code in the bible
that will bring
the religious establishment to its knees
oh no no wait no no no no that's not it
no that's that's the no that's right
that's right no dick and jane dick and
jane
that's da is code right that's davinci
code yeah it's just in my mind yeah
sounds like it's gonna be a good movie
that really is i can't wait to see that
but um
but uh no dick and jane is about a
suburban couple very very fetching very
fetching suburban couple yeah and uh who
lose everything because of an enron type
scandal and they turn to a life of crime
and eventually they show the
white-collar creeps what it's like to
get reamed nice i like that i like that
and then jane is uh kidnapped by an ape
you're getting your movies confused just
thought that was just not necessary sure
you know you don't need a competitive
marketplace i guess and stuff like that
and i want to bring this up i want to
bring it because you said competitive
and i want to bring this up i've known
you for a few years and uh very talented
idea what's that tiny ape
what seriously tiny little ape tiny
little a huge massive strength right but
he's tiny you can hardly see him right
so he could shoot right up your nose and
beat the hell out of your brain
that's a great movie what do you mean i
have an ape in my brain that's
ridiculous oh oh
he has an ape in his brain
i've got villain in my pants
it's like it
alien versus predator but now but you
are a competitive fellow i know that
about you you like to win and you are
the producer so what's wrong with that
nothing's wrong with it i wasn't picking
a fight i'm getting on me for no i'm not
getting on you i'm just saying that you
have and i admire this you've taken some
steps to ensure that fun with dick and
jane does very well this weekend against
the competition i uh i i'm i am a
producer i wear two hats now and so i
think that it's important that i
represent the movie well and uh that i
inspire confidence in the sony investor
okay very good um
so uh
so yeah i've done some moves i've made
some moves i think this is a really
smart idea i uh i actually bought movie
phone
you yourself bought movie phone phone
right and uh and i've just made a couple
of little changes
and uh and i'm still gonna advertise the
other movies and stuff but i i'd like us
to just have a little bit of an edge you
know really you have a phone back yeah
yeah we have one right here yeah we
always have a phone so just call a movie
phone and see what you've done all right
all right okay
i just thought this was a here we go
neat little competitive thing
interesting hello and welcome to movie
phone
for fun with dick and jane press one now
[Music]
for king kong suck eggs now
or cheaper by the dozen two go yourself
[Applause]
in the marketplace you know what i mean
i imagine you'll do very well you know
it they won't be able to tell but you
know okay let's let's talk about this
you're very uh you want to win but kong
is out there the movie kong it's been on
your mind you've referenced it
[Music]
that's a very good point you made my
argument
that's my argument god you're good kong
shilongi gong gone
you know but what do you do about kong
i'm worried about it man would you not
be worried about you know i've been
saying this all over town and i'm not
afraid to say it again kong is going
down the ape will fall tomorrow december
21st the ape will fall history will be
made blood will be shed prisoners will
not be protected by the geneva
convention
be there
you